watching eight news now live at four
the springs preserve is blooming again
the 188 girl to desert living reopened
today we've got our own jc fernandez
live out there he's been showing us some
cool stuff hey jc
hey kirsten this is great springs
preserve as you said has reopened today
this is tom with the springs preserve so
what actually is open right now all of
our outdoor areas
our trail system our botanical garden
our outdoor animal exhibits everything
in the outdoors is open and it's a
little bit let's walk this way because
we're in the botanical gardens
it's a little bit different though you
just can't show up right now no go to
springspreserve.org you purchase a
timed ticket for timed entry it's five
dollars for adults 250 for kids
3 to 17 and kids 2 and under free
there's so much to see down here it's a
very educational experience uh what
we're walking by some water tanks what
are we looking at and
this gives you a little idea of how what
water is used
where for example reclaimed water the
springs preserve is the first commercial
site in southern nevada you reuse all of
its water
now this is what's known as a gray water
tank and this is this is back in
the olden times right olden times and so
it's like the dishwater
anything that would hit a pipe but you
can reuse it to irrigate your landscape
beautiful stuff here and lands over here
windmill what do we have here
recreation of an old windmill of course
back in the day they would use those to
generate power or get water out of the
ground or to grind grains let's go
around this way because something that's
really cool when you guys come down here
springs preserve has reopened today
uh thursday through monday right
thursday through monday eight to four
now when you come down here something
really cool i never thought of you were
saying this gives people ideas when it
comes to landscaping their yards
if you want to redo your landscape or
install a new landscape you can come
down here and check out what
survives and thrives in our environment
how crazy to look at this joshua tree
this thing has
got to be at least 100 years old it's
very old it's seen some stuff
yeah yeah absolutely and the next one
down here come down here lance because
we have some other
um botanical things like how old is this
cactus right here the saguaro is a very
old saguaro
i can't tell you how old it is but it is
old keep on coming down here because
there's so much to see down here
at the springs preserve now when it
comes to food uh can people eat when
they come down here the divine cafe is
going to be open 11 to 2
thursday through uh monday and
we talked about this earlier the springs
preserve is the birthplace of las vegas
tom
why is it the birthplace of las vegas
this is the site of the original
artesian springs that gave las vegas the
name
the meadows as in las vegas which drew
the native americans drew the spanish
explorers the settlers and
eventually the railroad and that's why
we got the meadows mall across the
street
tom thank you so much the sprays
preserve has reopened today you can come
down and enjoy it
we'll send it back to you guys in the
studio jc we just got word that joshua
tree is 92 years old and frankly is
offended you said it was a hundred oh my
god
yeah i looked 100 he's only 92.
you guys the springs preserve i have so
many great memories from birthday
parties there when my daughter was just
three
to the blues and bruise fest brian that
was the first event we went to socially
almost eight years ago
jc kirsten loved the wine nights yes
those are great too
have you ever been there to those jason
that was a good invitation
and soon you can assume we have weddings
here all of us can return here to
springs preserve
okay wonderful such a great place over
there thank you jc thanks for playing
along
thanks jc yes i love you guys
i'll see you guys